[Musique]
so jowood bois soldats c'est ainsi qu'on
l'appelle dans les pays anglophones un
nom inspiré de son bruit quand ces
petits fruits gros comme des grains de
poivre explose ils produisent le son
d'un tir de mosquées en dehors de cette
période celui qu'on appelle chez nous
bois m'habille chuchote dans le vent
comme tous les arbres on le retrouve de
la floride au nord du venezuela et dans
toute l'amérique centrale et bien sûr
aux antilles
inscrit à la liste des espèces protégées
depuis 1988 cet arbuste discrète fleurs
jaunes mesure généralement entre 3 à 6
mètres mais peut parfois atteindre les
20 mètres il présente des feuilles
ovales légèrement poilie un profil
commun à de nombreuses plantes mais le
secret de colombe in haiti cas c'est son
nom scientifique ne se cache pas dans
ses feuilles
c'est son écorce qui est généralement
exploités
une fois séchées les corps s'est aussi
refusée en tisane dans les usages sensé
straw le bois may be est utilisé contre
les rhumatismes la fatigue la diarrhée
ou en diurétique il est aussi réputé
être bon pour le foie
il est utilisé en boisson tonifiante et
on lui prête des vertus aphrodisiaques
une étude caribéenne a d'ailleurs
confirmé qu'il faisait baisser la
pression sanguine
en analysant que lou brina elliptique à
on trouve des tanins une substance
végétale neudorf à l'action
antibiotiques et antioxydantes et ce
n'est pas tout
les recherches du parc ont mis en
évidence une autre molécule du bois ma
visite au niveau du parme notera bon
porter sur les corses étant donné que
c'est cette partie consommés au niveau
des usages traditionnels à partir de
cette écorce on a fait un certain nombre
d' extrême dont l'huile essentielle et
on a pu faire ce qu'on appelle un
screening phytochimiques stade une étude
de composition des molécules d'intérêt
présente dans les extraits parmi les
résultats obtenus on peut citer il faut
entretenir en saponines les saponines
sont des tensioactifs les tensions actif
ce sont des molécules qui ont une
capacité de faire mousser on retrouve
les tensioactifs dans les savons dans
les shampooings et par rapport à cette
forte teneur en saponines un usage qui
pourrait être fait de cette école c'est
pour la réalisation de produits
cosmétiques
et les produits moussants ne sont pas
les seuls à pouvoir bénéficier des
propriétés du bois m'habille d'autres
pistes cosmétiques notamment en
parfumerie sont envisagées dénis se sont
penchés sur les odeurs de l'huile
essentielle des corses de colomb rina et
leyti kâ ayant décelé des notes de
cyprès et des notes manteau lit
une autre voix se dessine donc pour le
bois m'habille mais attention quel que
soit l'usagé que vous en faites il faut
toujours être prudent si les plantes
peuvent soigner mieux vaut demander
conseil à votre médecin
[Musique]